[Music]
these are the horses that don't fit in
in any other place
all of these abandoned animals for
getting sent to slaughter they would
have been killed I think what they're
doing here is incredible
[Music]
I'm born and raised in New York City I
still live here in base here even though
most of my work is pretty far away and
abroad you get into this city life and
it's really important to get away from
all of that and to go somewhere that's
closer to nature but also have the
opportunity to slow down I'm on
assignment for National Geographic I'm
going up to rosemary farm sanctuary
which is a horse rescue in upstate New
York is this really interesting place
where horses are living a life that
you're not accustomed to seeing they're
letting animals live in a really
different and unique way and the animals
are relating to people in a really
unique way I hope that I can capture
that with the images and people can read
this story and maybe it's just a break
from the normal news that they're
looking at every story that you tell
doesn't have to be so dark and difficult
and gritty
[Music]
Nimmo is an unusual donkey this is not
normal donkey behavior when he was at
the hospital and we had his leg
amputated and they started teaching him
how to wear his prosthetic they spent a
lot of time with him and one person
would sit at his head and cuddle and the
other person would put the leg on and so
he developed this routine something I
really wanted to capture was putting on
Nemo's prosthetic leg and I know it was
just a really big part of their daily
routine there for the people but then
also for a Nemo come on Nemo
he was injured when he was really little
and it's not normal for equine animals
to live if they lose a limb it's pretty
cool to watch the journey of this really
resilient and inspiring little creature
[Music]
[Applause]
I never know where I'm gonna find
inspiration you know it's oftentimes
comes from just sort of stories and
sometimes it comes from chance there's
this energy in here so that's something
I really wanted to take I really wanted
to just sort of capture a moment where
you could feel the energy of all the
horses is one the feeling of them as a
herd and the strength of that but it's
also dangerous like these are really
powerful creatures and there's also you
know a lot of them they were put up to
slaughter because they won't obey and
they won't act like what people consider
you know a normal horse to act like and
that's okay you know like they get to be
free there but then like I'm on their
turf
[Music]
with everything that's going on in the
world especially what's happening to the
environment it's almost like
photographing a way of life where
there's this really deep connection with
nature and this interconnectedness
between people and animals it's almost
like you're capturing history this is
just as important as like any huge news
story it's just a little harder to grasp
when I shot something special I know
immediately everything comes together
and it just says something much more
than what you're seeing in front of you
[Music]